- You're from Iran, but
when did you move to the US?
It was when you were pretty young, right?
- Yeah. I was about three years old
when we came here and yeah
I was born in Iran, like
post revolution Iran.
My dad had to leave
shortly after I was born.
And then my mom and I went to,
we had to go to Germany for a year
while our immigration
papers were all sorted.
And then I met my dad again
at the airport in LA when I was three.
- Wow.
That's incredibly difficult.
- Wild. Yeah.
And like, you know, I'm
sure a lot of immigrant kids
can relate to this
but when your parents move here,
you're sort of assimilating
to this new culture at
the same time they are.
And you're the one in school.
So a lot of times, like, you're the one
you feel like the parent teaching
them how things are done.
Yeah. Like you have to
sit them down and be like,
okay so there's this thing called prom.
Like, I'm going to need a dress.
I will be attending a
Benihana's beforehand
with my classmates,
like, let me walk you through this.
Or like, my mom would make
these incredible meals
for me to send to school.
But I'm like, I love you.
Like, I will get absolutely annihilated
if I bring a lamb stew to
an American high school.
- Yeah I will end up
in a trash can (laughs)